wie du guckst in die kamera während du
meditiert wer macht denn so was ich
meine
das heißt soft focus in der sprache der
meditation der soft focus ich sehe du
hast wirklich also weniger ahnung als
ich seit den ersten beiden titel die
wahnsinnig erfolgreich waren hat ferrari
also den stellenwert eines group er
versucht uns die welt zu erklären ich
werde jetzt mal sagen was nicht oder
stein haben ja anvertraut hat nämlich
ärzte lieben harry und zwar
wahrscheinlich genau wegen dieser
diagnostik die erde anstellt und die so
wunderbar eindeutig ist und ich finde
seine vergleiche gerade so immer mit
könig der löwen und er hat sehr schöne
bilder und das ist auch dann wie immer
so ja ich bin zwar der nord auf dem
pausenhof aber ich möchte gerne darauf
hinweisen dass ich auch noch ein
bisschen poppiger das wissen ich habe
auch wenig der löwen gesehen nein ich
finde seine begabung besteht auch darin
dass er große umfassende historische
zusammenhänge auf den punkt bringen kann
und manchmal auch kalkulierte
provokation natürlich mit einbezieht
einer dann solche doch sehr generellen
weisheiten von sich gibt zb was wirklich
funktioniert wird früher oder später von
allen übernommen
oder dass die erfolgreichen staaten
eigentlich einander immer gleichen das
finde ich hochgradig fragwürdig diese
empfehlung von meditation auch ein
bisschen im sinne von allheilmittel das
ist ein bisschen das was gewinnes
paltrow macht mit kaffee darm spülung
mittel gegen alle übel dieser welt jetzt
machen wir wer länger durchhält ohne was
zu sagen meditieren bitte schon dabei
ist bis jetzt ging ich immer davon aus
der mensch ist was er weiß und nicht das
was er hat da bist du ja andere ansicht
wie bitte hallo das ist alles viel zu
komplex und dann bin ich auch noch
andere als ich ich sage meinen kindern
immer wissen bleibt euch aus sehen
vergeht besitz kann vergänglich sein und
so weiter aber das was ihr im kopf habe
davon könnt ihr jederzeit profitieren
ferrari sagt wissen muss man nicht mehr
sich selbst aneignen
aber man wird in zukunft sicherlich in
der menschheit eingeteilt durchs haben
ich glaube wir sogar ganz
wenig untersagen vor einer mahnung
abgesehen davon dass nikola mich für ein
materialistisches monster hält sind wir
total eine ansicht über den mittelweg
[Musik]